Redfin shuts home flipping business lays
off 13 percent of Staff in slumping
housing market this is a Wall Street
Journal story they let off 13 percent of
its staff on Wednesday and close its
home flipping unit saying the operation
was too expensive and too risky to
continue the seattle-based company which
operates a real estate brokerage at home
listing websites said the decisions were
made because it's it is predicting that
the real estate market is going to be
smaller next year they're not even
talking about 2022 2023 smaller next
year and its home flipping business is
losing money it previously laid off
eight percent of its Workforce in June
of this year the closure of redfin's
Home flipping business Redfin now
follows Open Door Technologies Inc
posting record losses last week the
biggest home flipping company sold too
many homes for less than their purchase
price Tom what is going on here give us
an update on the market and layoffs well
first of all redfin's just the beginning
on the real estate side you're going to
see Zillow you're going to see others
that are in real estate they're going to
be making adjustments and the ones that
made it easy for you to watch an
internet seminar and buy real estate you
too can be a flipper all those folks
watching those seminars on YouTube you
know and some of them are good
educational about real estate but others
we know they're scam artists well those
folks are the ones that go into Redfin
and going to Zillow trying to start
their home flipping business and the
real estate market is just not there I
think that's only part of the story
because interest rates and layoffs are
coming that sector it's beyond
Zuckerberg the rumor before the election
was a thousand people would be laid off
and many people including me this is at
Facebook yeah Facebook meta they sit
from a thousand to and then they did
eleven thousand that's correct the leak
that was out before the election they
believed was inside an intentional news
leak to kind of soften the blow and then
they laid off eleven thousand although
Facebook was up in after hours trading
just as coach because what is the market
like admissions of errors and then
reduction of cost and so there the other
thing that really surprised me is stripe
because you know stripe is huge or
bigger than American Express by value
and they're laying off 15 of their
Workforce and I'm going to read you
something this was I think good
leadership and valuetainment we're out
there talking leadership and helping
people grow their companies and giving
them examples of how to do it here's a
way to be honest with your people so
this is the leadership at stripe laying
off 15 percent
in making these head count changes
team stripe might reasonably wonder
whether Stripes leadership made some
errors of judgment
well we'll go further than that in our
view we made two very consequential
mistakes not just errors of judgment and
we want to highlight them here we were
too optimistic about the near-term
growth in 2022-23 and we grew our
operating costs too quickly we have to
correct these and that's leadership
coming forward and just saying hey you
know I thought there was a party going
on in the economy I grew too quick too
much but this is just the beginning
Stripes layoffs Redfin layoffs the
zillow's reportedly coming and then meta
laying off more than they thought this
is just the beginning this is the
economic correction that we've been
talking about makes sense by the way we
got the the great Dave Rubin here if we
can open up the volume and let him in
but go ahead you were saying
um well essentially what I think is
happening is you talked about how it's
been fake like everything that's
happened over the last couple years has
been fake printing money and how money
flows to the top right
if you look at all these major asset
classes whether it's the Dow whether
it's s p the NASDAQ Bitcoin ethereum the
list goes on and on and on basically
what's happening is just it's reverting
to where it was back in 2020 March of
2020. now there's you can give us some
case examples like apple is up huge like
way above where it is 2020 and that has
not reverted but then you have companies
like Facebook that have done the exact
opposite it's almost an inverted
situation but
all everything you talk about being fake
there he is baby everything you talk
about printing money being fake this is
all basically what's happening right now
no and and and it's great to see who was
really having a lot of fake success and
real success and the man that just came
in here he's definitely having a lot of
real friends he's gonna fix it
good to have you on oh it's fantastic to
have Davon here uh but but by the way
while to stay on the story before we
wrap it up and I'm gonna go straight to
Dave's commentary and thoughts on what
happened uh uh yesterday so Greg uh Cher
whom I had dinner with last night he was
at the office here he uh we were talking
about FTX yeah so FTX goes from a 32
billion dollar company to 16 billion
dollar company to binance says yeah
we'll give you a billion dollars to help
you bail yourself out and then they
change their minds and they said no
we're not giving you the billion dollars
and so this is a company that could
potentially go from 32 billion to 16b
billion to zero in no time and the
founder gave 39 million dollars to
democratic super Pacs and one of the
other Executives that owns a lot of
shares in the company gave 19 million
dollars to Republican super Pacs that's
Ryan salami that gave a 19 million
dollars great last name so this is
what's taking place with this company
Venture funds invested around two
billion dollars into the company most
recently added 32 billion dollar
valuation without a single board seat in
return did you hear what I just said Tom
2 billion 32 billion evaluation with
zero board seats in return and these are
not lame people that don't know how to
negotiate board seats in fact it's
unclear if FTX even has a board of
directors audit committee CFO Chief
compliance officer instead it just seems
to have a some sort of VC advisory
committee here's who was involved FTX
backers include Sequoia which once sued
binance for unrelated reasons
time SoftBank tiger Global Bond
BlackRock light speed Insight Partners
rivet Capital race Capital all of these
guys invested in in the point of this
article is saying that at the very least
the FTA experience will put a major
Chill on Venture investments in crypto
even in unaffected areas like
decentralized Finance if FTX can go from
32 billion to zero maybe in just 36
hours who's to say the same can't happen
elsewhere why would LPS take the chance
this is a very very legit big hit to the
crypto Community think about this so
32 billion valuation I give you a
billion dollars investment now you're
worth 33 billion dollars because you got
my cash
I only own 133rd
you think of it that way and so
if I want to Triple my money that
thing's got to be worth a hundred
billion dollars someday and so there was
apparently feelings that there is more
than just frothiness in the mod in the
market you know what I mean this was a
this was a root beer shaken up and then
you open it in a crowded room I mean
this is huge all over your face now oh
yeah all over everything but think about
that Pat because you make investments
bad visual for Tom but go ahead
don't get distracted Stay Focus this is
Adam's distracting yeah I know but think
about that you make angel Investments
and you make more than Angel investment
serious Investments would you invest in
something where you've got one Thirty
third of it that's an insight and a
tripling just to Triple your money or
double your money the thing's got to be
worth 66 billion dollars that's that's
when you know that's when you know when
when people are trying to be that greedy
that late last year at Super Bowl the
whole Super Bowl was about crypto yeah
all you have to say is who won the Super
Bowl last year Chris crypto I don't know
who won the Super Bowl LA Rams I can
tell you crypto one and you know by the
way FTX Tom Brady is a part of it Jose's
a part of it you know how many
celebrities are a part of it left and
right people were involved in this uh
but uh but that's a whole different
conversation on what's taking place I
know a lot of guys that are on the
crypto Community who's they put 95
percent of their Savings in it like I'm
talking 95 of their Savings in it and
they're doing Uber right now late at
night because Pat you're not supposed to
bring it up I didn't want to do it but
sorry but listen props to your 4.9 star
Don Uber thank you you got to be proud
listen at least I'm gonna give you the
shout out so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then then when
those three people weren't in the office
they had to order 58 of them because
people wanted the future looks bright
hat especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]